selon mes informations
hugo aussi à manger non tous mangent du
coup
c'est à dire que quand ils revenaient
des dîners les deuxièmes dîner dans le
bungalow il rapportait de la nourriture
aux autres pour que les ont pas
lancement et je crois qu hugo a cédé à
la tentation est ce qu'il a mangé de
ride à manger d'après la bassure mais
oui il vous avez des infos oui
effectivement les 10 nice est choquant
après gilles parlé de des bananes et du
coca c'est pas la première fois que la
production donne à manger où l audace et
c'est arrivé c'est arrivé quand même
mais c'est incroyable alors wafa quand
on sent ça tu avais je mange et toi tu
avais donné de malheur nous on nous
avait donné un milkshake à la banane
avec du chocolat mais c'était vraiment
pour qu'on ait du peps juste avant les
airs si vous allez voir les infos sur
koh lanta qu'on a à venir là elles sont
folles encore dîner clandestins le nom
des candidats à l'initiative enfin
révélé alors eh oui vous entendez paul
besset que la 4e info vous rendez compte
qu'à l'époque
on savait déjà que y'aura avait fait
rapatrier de la nourriture sur son île
est en fait les deux protagonistes de ce
dîner côlon du sein s'est close up et
laurent qui sont non je pense à moi
c'est de m c'est le plus maintenant
claude et laurent ouais c'est claude et
laurent et en plus ce qui est assez
dingue c'est que il aurait parce que
voilà ils se sont fait donner de la faim
donner de la nourriture par les gens par
les touristes qui étaient sur place il
aurait proposé voilà de leur donner de
l'argent une fois rentrer en france une
salle j'y crois pas mal alors alors sisi
par excès et même une photo ja va mieux
alors ils sont là mais je ne crois pas
il aurait même été surnommée la fête ils
ont été surnommés la team roublard par
leurs collègues d'après une info du
parisien une nuit à 3 heures les deux
candidats auraient pris l'initiative de
quitter ce campement post conseils pour
aller m'ont dit de la nourriture il
aurait aussi été à l'initiative de repas
chez l'habitant pour l'heure pour les
convaincre claude et laurent aurait
promis de leur envoyer de l'argent une
foire aux cinq beach voilà exactement
l'argent bah oui je pense on dit que oui
sauf que le gouvernement donne être pris
en photo d'accord exactement très tôt
donc une preuve matérielle existerait de
ce repas elle est aussi trop tôt il
aurait été capable avec trois salles et
la prod l'a récupérée et l'appliquent va
bien récupérer bien quoi
franchement c'est c'est hyper dur passe
mais là est la prod à l'afrique le
cloisonné évidemment nous comme
information que la prod aurait bien sûr
renchérit pour garder cette photo fut
salée à tahiti et a demandé aux gens de
la vie qui n'est pas une photo je sais
qu'un jour il est rasé qui viennent
passer une photo qui a été effectivement
prises à tahiti des deux ferrari dont je
bats et que québec a demandé et que
quelqu'un récupérer et selon mes
informations ce quelqu'un c'est un
ancien aventurier qu'il l'a quand il a
récupéré la photo je peux pas donner son
nom quand il a récupéré la photo il est
allé voir la prod ou tf1 il aura des
voix la soie soit vous vous prenez
l'initiative de dire ce qui s'est passé
moi je fais tout sauter collants
moulants c'est là où ça a dégénéré à
cette photo moi je ne les ai pas vus
mais j'aimais l'idée qu'une femme a fait
licencier sa manche et voilà ils sont
allés à l'oit son entraînement voilà il
ya quatre personnes sur la photo il y
avait quatre candidats sur la photo il y
aurait un jade claude laurent et s'il
est un ange annonce peut pousser
les coiffes à ceci que tu entends des
difficultés sociales
la vérité on t'adore wafa meschonnic
c'est malheureusement aussi ça ne fait
pas
un chat dix ados searle et marc tu vois
pas que c'est pas bien oui alors il faut
préciser moi j'adore jeune je n'ai pas
vu la photo mais j'ai parlé aujourd'hui
avec quelqu'un qui a vu la photo la
photo ils sont mis à quatre candidats et
cette photo effectivement elle est en
tain en train d'être achetés et le crime
a sorti le nuage
t elle et elle et elle est acheminée le
prix le prix est de plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'euros oui majeur dizaines
de milliers d'euros que je veux dire
cette photo elle va sortir de tout mais
voilà